[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour faire ensemble le point sur
l'actualité du jour est aussi de la
semaine voici les titres de cet hebdo le
centre de protection maternelle et
infantile de guyancourt des ménages
c'est dorénavant rues du centre qu'il
faudra se rendre à l'inauguration du
lieu d'accueil vient de se tenir
pendant ce temps attrape une nouvelle
association vient de se lancer coeur de
trappes une association fondée par le
premier adjoint au maire ali rabais pour
permettre à chacun d'imaginer l'avenir
de la commune et agir en d'autres termes
la campagne des municipales semblent se
préparer à lire à b sera en plateau et
puis comme chaque vendredi le point sur
l'essentiel de la semaine des
commémorations du 11 novembre à la
mobilisation qui s'organise contre la
hausse du prix de l'essence ce sera le
17 novembre avant de retrouver donc
l'invité de cette semaine direction
guyancourt le centre de protection
maternelle et infantile vient de
s'installer dans ses nouveaux locaux
afin de répondre plus rapidement aux
demandes des usagers le point sur les
services proposés trouver de l'aide
concernant son enfant dans une même
structure c'est ce que viennent chercher
les familles dans le centre de
protection maternelle et infantile de
guyancourt
le nouveau site plus adapté répond aux
exigences réglementaires et aux besoins
des usagers des professionnels le
département des yvelines investi plus de
160000 euros dans les travaux de
rénovation la pmi de guyancourt a été
inaugurée jeudi 8 novembre la pmi a
changé d'emplacement puisque les locaux
étaient trop petits et puis qui à un
moment là le conseil départemental avait
choisi effectivement de de fermer de
nombreuses pmi sur l'ensemble des
territoires donc nous on s'est battu sur
guyancourt avec la population pour
garder notre pays me la pmi a changé de
lieu mais est resté sur lui en cours et
donc la possibilité à toutes les
familles de pouvoir l'utiliser et des
familles qui sont aussi sur les
territoires juste à côté
auparavant il fallait attendre entre 4 à
6 semaines pour avoir un rendez vous
mais l'équipe du nouveau centre composée
d'un médecin de consultation trois
vacataires une sage-femme deux
assistantes administratives et c'est
depuis et reculent trice permettent un
rendez-vous sous 15 jours
on va pouvoir voilà diminuer les listes
d'attentes pour le public
en proposant davantage de consultations
également davantage de permanence qui
sont des temps d'accueil sans rendez
vous cela va nous permettre également de
pouvoir mettre en place des actions
collectives donc qui était préparé
mais n'ayant pas de salle prévue à cet
effet dans les anciens locaux on pouvait
pas les mettre en place d'autres projets
vont émerger à destination des parents
la ville de guyancourt va créer un lieu
d'accueil parents enfants mais aussi un
ram un réseau d'assistantes maternelles
coeur de trappes c'est donc le nom de
cette nouvelle association lancée par
ali rabais bienvenus en plateau et je
vais tout de suite corrigé vous n'êtes
pas première adjoint à trappes mais
adjoint à la jeunesse notamment sur la
commune
alors quel est l'objectif de cette
association coeur de trappes j'évoquais
tout à l'heure une volonté de faire
foisonner un petit peu les idées des uns
et des autres c'est absolument ça moi je
suis un responsable politique je suis
adjoint au maire dans ma ville je suis
militant par ailleurs dans le mouvement
génération de benoît hamon
mais je conçois pas l'action politique
uniquement comme un rendez vous
électoral tous les cinq ou six ans avec
les concitoyens et en particulier les
trappistes
je pense que les français en ont marre
des politiques qui débarque le jour des
élections ou l'avant veille sur les
marchés et qui leur distribuent des
tracts dans ma façon d'agir au quotidien
comme adjoint au maire comme élu local
je travaille déjà avec des associations
des forces vives des bénévoles des
parents d'élèves des commerçants qui
nous interpelle tous les jours quand on
est élu et quand on est actif sur le
terrain je prétends être un peu actif
sur le terrain en tout cas on me
reconnaît sa trappe on se fait
interpeller tout le temps quand on va
acheter sa baguette quand on fait ses
courses au supermarché et on nous
interpellent pour nous dire voilà
j'étais l'idée tel projet j'ai un neveu
qui cherchent un apprentissage et qui a
besoin d'un employeur tout ce travail et
toutes ces rencontres que j'ai pu faire
moi pendant quelques années de mandat un
moment donné je me suis dit 'il est
temps que je permettent à des gens de
trappes qui sont engagés au quotidien
ils sont des centaines de trappistes
engagé de se croiser de se rencontrer de
mêlée lors de leur énergie et de monter
des projets ensemble
il faut pas attendre les élections
municipales pour se mettre au travail la
ville on
la change maintenant pendant le mandat
les élus le fond mais les concitoyens le
font les français les trappistes
changent leur ville au quotidien c'est
eux qui encadrent les enfants dans les
associations sportives
c'est eux qui accompagnent des enfants
et visites culturelles au château de
versailles ou à paris c'est pas les élus
qui le font c'est les trappistes au
quotidien nous on est là pour aider
accompagner permettre que les projets se
développent donc je crois vraiment que
l'action elle se fait à la fois pendant
le mandat pendant les élections et qu'il
faut interagir mêler nos énergies
apprendre à nous connaître et ma grande
fierté hier c'était de réussir à réunir
dans la salle picasso à trappes
lors du lancement officiel de
l'association coeur de trappes plus de
120 personnes et on y trouvait des
jeunes de 18 ans des personnes âgées de
75 ans chacun venait parler de ce qui
lui tient à coeur monter des projets et
on va s'entraider
on aura des jeunes de 20 ans qui vont
aller organiser des voyages des vacances
pour des personnes âgées
on aura des personnes qui travaillent
qui vont accompagner des personnes qui
sont au chômage
on va essayer de monter un certain
nombre de projets que vous le verrez
j'imagine dans les images mais le
foisonnement des idées très riche
pendant deux heures deux heures et demie
a permis de faire émerger plein d'idées
plein de priorité et on va s'atteler à
les mettre en oeuvre dans les années qui
viennent mais pour autant c'est le
travail que vous menez en tant qu'élu
directement que vous êtes censés mener
en tant qu'élu el assad vient se greffer
en plus c'est à dire que l'on mairie on
ne fait pas suffisamment de choses il
faut trouver d'autres moyens au sia sur
wii
je suis parfaitement convaincu que si on
attend tout je passe mon temps à le
répéter aux enfants aux jeunes aux
familles si on attend tout de la part
des élus ou de la part de la mairie on
s'en sortira pas dans une ville comme
trappe qui a énormément de défis à
relever on le sait c'est un territoire
très particulier unique en france
quasiment qui a fait émerger des stars
connues au niveau international dans le
foot dans le cinéma mais moi on a un
territoire unique mais on ne relèvera
pas les défis qui se posent à nous si
tout le monde s'y met pas alors si
chacun se dise c'est la faute de la
mairie où c'est à la mairie de trouver
des solutions on ne progressera pas
collectivement évidemment que les élus
ne peuvent pas tout faire tout seul
évidemment que les bénévoles les
trappistes dans les associations ne
peuvent pas tout faire tout seul mais en
se coalisent en est capable de faire des
miracles est en train de dire qu'il faut
traverser la rue pour trouver un travail
pas du tout certainement pas parce que
je sais comme c'est dur de trouver un
travail et j'en croise tous les jours
moi des gens qui traversent la rue matin
midi et soir
- les jeunes gens qui viennent me voir
je vais vous donner une anecdote
je reçois des cv de jeunes gens qui
cherchent un apprentissage ou un job qui
sont diplômés à bac + 5 par moment et
qui quand ils mettent leur adresse il
met j'habite chez paru pas bio pablo
picasso 78190 saint quentin en yvelines
à moins que ça ait changé soixante dix
890 et le code postal de la ville de
trappes saint quentin en yvelines n'est
pas une commune mais au quotidien les
jeunes trappistes ont conscience même
quand ils sont très diplômés de subir
des discriminations quand on leur dit
traverser la route et vous allez trouver
un boulot
excusez moi mais un ingénieur qui a fait
un bac +5 en mécanique automobile il
aimerait bien éviter d'aller faire un
serveur dans un café puisqu'il n'a pas
travaillé pour ça est ce que vous êtes
en campagne actuellement pour les
prochaines et les élections municipales
voit la réponse est claire c'est non
parce que je joue des marges arrière et
semble un peu ça peut y ressembler je
peux comprendre qu'on interprète comme
ça la réponse est non
le jour où je serai candidat je le dirai
à mes concitoyens je vous le dirai à
vous la presse parce que j'aurai décider
le cas échéant si je considère que les
circonstances le permettent et que c'est
une option que qui est porté par ceux
qui m'entourent et par les trappistes
aujourd'hui je travaille dans une équipe
municipale avec un maire qui s'appelle
guy malandain qui a en vain en
transformer la ville embellit la ville
même les trappistes ne reconnaissent pas
leur propre ville et ce bilan moi je
m'inscris totalement dans son héritage
parce qu'il a fait du bon boulot tout
simplement donc je réagis pas exécuté
avec lui avec guy malandain justement
des initiatives pour pour l'association
bien sûr moi c'est une initiative que je
prends librement j'ai toujours été un
homme libre un élu libre guy malandain
le sait pertinemment
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est dans son
équipe et que j'ai des responsabilités
pas dans une caserne quand on est dans
une équipe municipale ont fait ses choix
on a le droit de prendre des initiatives
et évidemment je lui ai annoncé cette
initiative et je lui ai indiqué que de
nombreux trappistes la souhaitait et
qu'à mes yeux ma comme je vous le dis
comme je l'aï dit à guy malandain ma
conception de la vie politique ce n'est
pas s'engager sur les campagnes
électorales c'est agir tous les jours et
les élus parce que nous avons une
responsabilité particulière dans la
ville parce que nous avons des réseaux
mais je suis très fier d'avoir de très
nombreux réseaux y avait des profs qui
étaient là hier soir on avait des
responsables je vous disais
d'associations sportives culturelles etc
tous ces gens transforment trappe au
quotidien
quand on a la chance d'avoir ce réseau
là c'est pour moi un honneur un
privilège d'une grande fierté
on a le devoir de les réunir et les
faire bosser ensemble on va écouter les
trappistes justement qui était présent
hier quelques-uns et des attentes ils en
ont beaucoup écouté
j'attends des actions concrètes pour
améliorer le quotidien des jeunes
notamment de la ville je pense à la
formation par rapport à la rotation dans
les collèges
ou encore l'aide à la recherche de
stages d'apprentissage une première
emploi on attend quelque chose de bien
horribles sur trappe parce que c'est
vrai qu'à trappe il ya pas mal de choses
mais pour les seniors il ya pas grand
chose tirer la jeunesse vers le haut
ne laisser personne de côté surtout
c'est ça qui est important
voilà que ce soit dans le sport dans la
culture l'éducation
et
et aussi à tous qui l'environnement
aussi l'environnement dans lequel on vit
il faut que ça soit un environnement
digne des bâtiments des prestations tout
soit rénové entretenu le projet on va
dire et ambitieux pouvoir unir bat le
coeur de trappes tous ses habitants tous
ses citoyens
doit avoir un peu comment ça tourne
disque on a besoin de cette unité quoi
on a tellement entendu parler de trappes
en mal
rapport aux gens de l'extérieur genre
que j'espère que là avec ali on va
reparler de rendre bien de trappes
il faut parler en bien de trappes c'est
ça le plus important
une excellente conclusion il en parle
très bien les gens que vous avez
interviewé
vous voyez qu'il ya que du positif il ya
des projets des idées une anecdote c'est
la personne âgée pas la dernière
celle qui était en troisième position
dans votre reportage disait on fait des
choses à trappes et plein de bonnes
choses mais pour les personnes âgées il
n'y a pas suffisamment d'actions à ses
yeux cette personne et son épouse moi je
les croisais où vous marchez dimanche
dernier j'étais au marché avec quelques
amis et j'ai croisé une trappe hisse
parmi d'autres qui comme souvent m'a
pris par la manche il m'a dit monsieur
vous fait des bonnes choses d'ailleurs
sur la jeunesse je lui dis ça tombe bien
je suis a toujours la jeunesse merci du
compliment
elle m'a dit vous en faites pas assez
pour les personnes âgées on en fait pas
mal pour les personnes âgées
mais je lui dis venez jeudi à notre
rendez vous vous aurez l'occasion de
travailler avec ceux qui s'intéressent à
la question du bien vieillir attrape
c'est un de nos chantiers dans
l'association coeur de trappes et
proposer vos idées faites vos remarques
elle est venue avec son époux et elle a
contribué à nous donner des idées
maintenant les mettra en oeuvre ensemble
quelle est votre priorité pour la ville
de trappes justement toutes les
propositions qui ont été jetés là je
n'ai pas une seule
si je devais dire quelque chose qui est
ma conviction
guy malandain a fait un travail
absolument formidable pour rénover la
ville de trappes sert qu'on a maintenant
un écrin il reste évidemment des choses
à faire
malheureusement là des problèmes
d'insalubrité on a encore quelques
quartiers qui n'ont pas achevé leurs
rénovations et là on attend beaucoup de
l'état qui tardent à nous donner des
crédits pour faire la deuxième
rénovation urbaine de trappes mais quand
on aura fini ce travail là que fait très
bien guy malandain
quand on aura couvert la rn10 qui coupe
la ville en deux comme une cicatrice
il restera à faire à mes yeux le plus le
plus intéressant le plus enthousiasmant
le plus important aussi c'est recoudre
ce lien social qui est entretenue par
tous les gens qui étaient là qui ont
témoigné devant votre caméra mais qui
fait qu'on vit bien dans une ville parce
que on peut très bien avoir des murs
absolument formidable très joli mais
être malheureux dans son quartier dans
son dans sa cage d'escalier ou dans son
pavillon
si on bosse ensemble si on vit ensemble
dans un quartier ont créé un lien et un
amour de son voisin de son prochain qui
fait que c'est un plaisir de vie dans
cette ville les trappistes me le dit
souvent c'est un bonheur de vivre là
contrairement à ce que disent parfois
les médias de
la ville de trappes et je pense qu'on
peut aller beaucoup beaucoup plus loin
et faire en sorte que chacun y trouve sa
place
vous êtes aussi le porte parole du
mouvement générations avant gage et aux
côtés de benoît hamon qui a été élu
pendant un temps sur la commune de
trappes parler des municipales forcément
de votre engagement pour la commune au
delà de ça juste avant il ya quand même
une autre une autre élection ce sont les
élections européennes est ce que vous
serez candidat par exemple sur ces
élections
non pas du tout parce que c'est pas du
tout ma sensibilité personnelle chacun a
sa compétence et son domaine d'intérêt
moi je suis vraiment un homme qui aime
agir localement au plus proche des
habitants j'ai besoin d'être en contact
vraiment physique quotidien et avec les
habitants et le mandat européen est un
mandat très intéressant enthousiasmant
ils méritent des techniciens et des
experts que la liste d'ailleurs que
proposera benoît hamon son mouvement et
j'espère plus largement que proposera
plusieurs formations de gauche sera à la
hauteur des attentes pour les
européennes mais à titre personnel vous
ma d'intéressement sous cape mais vous
avez évoqué justement cette cette liste
ouverte large benoît bons voeux des
candidatures citoyenne absolument pas ce
qu'ils arrivent à regrouper à fédérer
autour de cette idée soit lu ment mais
cette démarche me plaît c'est pour ça
que dans ce mouvement c'est qu'on n'est
pas dans une logique des vieux appareils
partisans chacun met son étiquette mais
ils listent une ribambelle d'élus locaux
ou nationaux qui rêve d'avoir un mandat
européen
l'objectif c'est de dire aux citoyens
prenaient le pouvoir notre mouvement est
fait c'est pas un parti politique comme
les autres c'est un mouvement qui est
traversée par des gens très différents
de cultures différentes
il est fait pour être pris par les
citoyens donc n'importe qui peut sur le
site internet du mouvement générations
qui respecte déposer sa candidature et
on a déjà des présidents de grandes
associations nationales de solidarité on
a des artistes
on a des champions dans le monde sportif
qui nous ont sollicités et qui sont
intéressés par la démarche
donc nous on est dans une démarche
d'ouverture on en est pas à
l'affirmation de dire nous allons
déposer une liste 100% génération ce
sera de toute façon lui citoyenne et
nous proposons aux autres formations de
gauche de travailler ensemble pour qu'on
soit capable de proposer aux français un
vrai projet européen ambitieux
écologistes et qui combattra pour la
justice sociale c'est clairement ce qui
manque en europe aujourd'hui
merci al arab et adjoint au maire de
trappes et bien que fondateur aussi sur
cette commune de cette nouvelle
association coeur de trappes dont nous
avons
il ya quelques instants
[Musique]
le résumé de l'actualité comme chaque
fin de semaine avec notamment les
commémorations de la grande guerre les
communes multiplient hommage et
cérémonie avant le grand rendez vous du
11 novembre exemple à versailles avec
une exposition sur les lendemains de la
victoire des documents d'archivés ou
encore des documents issus des greniers
des habitants sont à découvrir le 11
novembre 1918 l'armistice était signé
mais la grande guerre laisse ses traces
certains soldats mettent plusieurs mois
à revenir des tranchées et la vie
quotidienne reste difficile c'est cette
période que la ville de versailles et le
comité des anciens combattants ont
choisi de mettre en avant dans leurs
expositions de versailles
au lendemain de la victoire de 1918 j'ai
voulu me décaler un petit peu en
présentant la prémisse this pour
démontrer d'une part que les soldats ne
sont pas revenus
enfin 18 mai beaucoup 1019 voire plus
tard et puis nous avons voulu quand même
personnaliser cette exposition par des
par une présentation de documents
appartenant aux familles versaillaise
les documents qui s'ajoutent à ceux des
archives municipales départementales et
enrichissent l'exposition
là vous avez un document qui est assez
rare qui est une lettre à l'encré
sympathique de façon à contourner les
censures souvent donc les soldats des
poilus écrivait alors famille avec de
l'encré sympathique était révélé ce
travail est aussi intergénérationnel
depuis plusieurs années une
collaboration se fait avec les collèges
et des lycées du département
leurs productions font pleinement partie
de l'exposition et présentent leur
propre regard sur cette époque monsieur
de moura donc à rassembler plusieurs
lycées pour les faire travailler sur les
commémorations du centenaire
donc vous avez beaucoup de dessins qui
ont été faits et qui ont été faits par
thèmes ainsi vous avez ce souvenir
combattre souffrir et c'est avec des
des dessins en rapport un travail de
mémoire et de partage entre les
générations bien accompli les jeunes
yvelinois aussi travailler une pièce de
théâtre pour accompagner l'exposition le
grand festin sème les 10 novembre à
20h30 à l'espace jean racine
ce dimanche nous commémorons donc la
date du 11 novembre 1918 jour de la
signature de l'armistice mettant fin à
la première guerre mondiale toutes les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
organise leur cérémonie cela débute à
9h30 à montigny le bretonneux rendez
vous fixé à 10 heures 30 au monument aux
morts pour frapper aux clayes-sous-bois
sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville à
magny les hameaux et au cimetière de
maurepas à la verrière un cortège se
réunira dès 10h15 à 10h15 également pour
elancourt le départ est prévu à la ferme
du mousseau plusieurs cérémonies vont
débuter à 11h c'est le cas coignard et à
plaisir et qui convient leurs
populations devant le monument aux morts
et puis aussi pour guyancourt et voisins
le bretonneux rassemblement devant elle
et mary enfin à villepreux
la journée sera lancée à partir de 9h et
ne reviendront bien évidemment sur ces
différentes commémorations dans notre
édition la du journal lundi l es 17
novembre quelques 400 manifestations
vont se dérouler partout en france afin
de protester contre la hausse du
carburant la nationale 10 l'autoroute
a12 ou encore à xiii seront touchés à
daniel guerreau le président de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes étaient sur ce plateau
mardi dernier nous sommes pas
organisateur de manifestation mais nous
nous avons déjà alerté le prix dans la
république dès le mois de septembre delà
du mécontentement qui montante qui monte
dans le pays et nous avons lancé coup de
pompe c'est aux ut pontpoint comme en
demandant à chaque citoyen concerné de
de cliquer sur le lien et vous aviez une
lettre que vous pouvez envoyer au
président la république avec le ticket 2
de caisse de la station-service voilà
donc on a senti ce mouvement monte pas
ce qu'on comprend pas bien et on nous a
mis 7 centimes d'augmentation sur le
diesel mais aussi 4 centimes sur
l'essence et le sud du désert qui
aujourd'hui au dessus du prix de
l'essence
oui pratiquement et les gens comprennent
pas puisque jusqu'à il ya quelques
années on encourager les gens à acheter
des moteurs diesel et maintenant on
vient les taxes et on comprend pas bien
pourquoi et on voudrait nous faire
croire qu'il suffirait de taxer les
carburants en france pour réduire la
température de la planète de la vrai que
c'est quand même un peu gros
économie et la troisième édition du sky
business day au vélodrome national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout au long
de la journée de jeudi des dirigeants de
grandes entreprises de pme de tpe de
start up se sont rencontrés des
rendez-vous de 25 minutes pour se
découvrir tenter de convaincre et faire
des affaires plus de 1000 participants
représentant près de 700 entreprises
écouter jean michel fourgous le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
on est ici pour inventer pour pour pour
accélérer la croissance de nos
entreprises
et ça passe bien sûr par la création
d'événements de ce type
donc on est là pour que les petits
surtout aux entreprises qui ont du magic
fois à rentrer en relation avec une
grande entreprise avoir le bon décideurs
pour vendre leurs produits mais est bien
ici on est un démultiplicateur de
rencontres entre les petites entreprises
et les grosses entreprises pour qu'ils
travaillent plus ensemble
nous poursuivons notre tour des
principales informations de cette
semaine dans les yvelines avec un
premier déplacement pour la nouvelle à
rectrice charline avenel au collège les
molières des essarts le roi à
déplacement forcément marquée par le
contexte national à l'agression récente
au lycée branly de créteil ou encore l
annonce de mesures relatives à la
protection au sein des écoles souhaitée
par le ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer le reportage de manon
varaldo échanger sur les actions mises
en place pour préserver un climat
scolaire serein lors de sa venue au
collège les molières des essarts le roi
charline avenel a pu rencontrer
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
professeurs membres du rectorat parents
d'élèves
c'est un collège qui a su mettre en
place les conditions d'un climat apaisé
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a également présenté les mesures
annoncées par le ministre de l'éducation
sur la protection des écoles
parmi elles une organisation des
conseils de discipline simplifier la
présence d'un policier ou d'un gendarme
lorsque le contexte le nécessitent une
mesure effective dans le collège les
molières qui a déjà fait appel à une
policière
autre mesure annoncée une période
probatoire sera instaurée après une
exclusion
chaque jour l'élève fera le point sur sa
journée avec le cpe où le chef
d'établissement venir voir un adulte
pour qu on crée une situation de retour
à l'école me semble important le mot
quotidiens les plus gênants cette mesure
parce que c'est difficile pour nous
d'être au quotidien avec un et la
compliquer soigner le retour d'un élève
en difficulté ça me semble très
important
le mot quotidiennement et peut être un
peu compliqué être confrontés au manque
de respect d'un élève ou comment gérer
le retour d'un exclut les enseignants
ont interpellé la rectrice sur leur
besoin d'être accompagnés dans
l'exercice de l'autorité envers leurs
élèves ce qui ressort
des échanges que nous avons eus ce matin
c'est le besoin des enseignants d'être
accompagné dans l'exercice de leur
autorité et en cas de difficulté par
l'ensemble de la chaîne pédagogique et
aussi en matière de formation
prochainement l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative souhaite appliquer
des sanctions dites de
responsabilisation travaux d'intérêt
général devoirs supplémentaires
des mesures auxquelles les
établissements vont appel dans seulement
1% des cas on passe au sport avec
l'eco-trail dont le parcours vient
d'être dévoilée la course sera organisée
le 17 mars marc sparmont prochain au
départ toujours de l'île de loisirs de
50 ans d'être elle en pleine nature et
des coureurs qui vont au bout
d'eux-mêmes voici le programme de la 12e
édition de l'eco-trail le rendez-vous
proposera le 17 mars des courses de 18
30 45 et 80 km entre l'ouest parisien et
la tour eiffel plus de douze mille
participants sont attendus sur cette
épreuve
c'est devenu le plus gros rendez vous de
trail de début de saison où on peut
accueillir des élites les merdias lite
de la discipline et c'est aussi en
fonction des différentes des différents
formats de course de 18 ans 80 c'est
hyper ouvert ce qui fait que les gens on
en a de plus en plus qui s'inscrivent de
plus en plus tôt donc nous nous
inscrivions dès le mois de juillet
ça veut dire près de neuf mois avant
avant l'événement et on est complet on
est complet au mois de février
parmi les participants fabien parmentier
un coureur originaire de montigny le
bretonneux le runner a déjà participé à
11 édition de l'eco trail et repartir à
cette année sur le 80 km le départ est à
quelques kilomètres de chez moi
et puis ça permet surtout à ma famille
de me suivre en fait sur sur la totalité
du parcours
donc voilà c'est ma course le cas là moi
quoi avec le temps fabien parmentier
connaît parfaitement les pièges à éviter
sur ce départ à domicile depuis l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
faut se mettre dedans officiellement
faut rentrer dans la course retrouver le
bon rythme faut éviter de passes faire
d'entorse parce qu'effectivement on part
sur la base de loisirs de saint quentin
et puis on part dans un une espèce de
chant qui est relativement beau ce n'est
pas évident pour les scheer
donc faut faire fort à ses attentes il
faut trouver le bon rythme pas se cramer
trop vite
une stratégie qui l'aidera peut-être à
réaliser son objectif boucler cet ultra
trail avec un temps compris entre 8h30
et 9h30
[Musique]
chaque semaine nous jetons un coup
d'oeil au reste de l'actualité en
ile-de-france avec nos confrères de via
grand paris chaîne a retrouvé sur la tnt
aujourd'hui ils se sont penchés sur ces
passages piétons en 3d censé renforcer
la sécurité des passages piétons en
trois dimensions qui rime avec
incompréhension
la ville de paris expérimente ce nouveau
système censé faire ralentir les
automobilistes comme ici rue de l'ouest
dans le 14e arrondissement pour mesurer
la réussite de ce test les feux rouges
ont été coupées
résultat les riverains du mal à
traverser car l'effet 3d laisse à
désirer ball by me laisse dans
dans une indifférence la plus totale
voilà je vois pas que c'est une 3d je
pense que ça soit rue rue de l'ouest ont
même rue raymond losserand où
effectivement là on cherche un peu
ces passages piétons en 3d et on les
trouve absolument pas donc ça a été
malheureusement mal fait du côté des
automobilistes
le discours va dans le même sens la 3d
n'est vraiment pas convaincante en tant
qu'automobiliste j'ai l'impression quand
même que l'étude n'a pas ne pas pas
forcément ses fruits parce que l'aspect
qui était recherché c'est à dire
l'aspect 3d n'est pas forcément probants
pour moi en tous les cas en attendant un
premier bilan de la mairie de paris sur
ce dispositif
ce passage piéton 3d peine à convaincre
les habitants
au total cinq passages piétons 3d sont
en expérimentation dans la capitale
c'est la fin de cet hebdo excellent week
end le journal revient en direct lundi à
18h première rediffusion à 19 heures
[Musique]
pour